this program is brought to you by Emory
University
the mission of the urban health
initiative is to really understand this
diverse population in Atlanta
particularly the population is having a
harder time these days and to understand
some of the social determinants and
social context that cause people to be
less healthy and then bring the forces
of the university together to try to
change that so university researchers
professors those who work with students
that are the future professionals all
will come together so that we can find
all the different aspects of the social
determinants of health and see which
ones we can impact if the future
generations of medical professionals
doctors nurses public health
professionals would come out and work in
the communities that they think they
want to work in in the future and find
out if that suits them and if so then
learn how to work well with them and
then contribute to the body of knowledge
so that additional future generations
can work well to really make a
difference in reduce disparities that
would be a wonderful dream and a
wonderful outcome one of the most
exciting things are that people want to
volunteer so for example in the area of
the healing community center I've had a
physician's assistant a nurse a former
dean three residents just in the past
two weeks say I could volunteer some
time there I went to my own chiropractor
who said I will be more than happy to
give a half a day a week so what I'm
finding is that if more people know
about the healing community center we
can bring in more professionals and more
people of interest who will also begin
to understand that population and as we
spread that out then we can help change
the world which is of course our big
goal
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University